today's lecture is Paylor macadam who is
a postdoc here at the math department
taylor grew up in Texas California in
California or just California just
California I went to school in Texas and
California
he discovered around junior in junior
year of high school that she liked math
so some of you have a head start and she
graduated PhD from UC San Diego and now
she's here doing dynamics and you're
gonna find out a little bit of what she
does so let's have a hand for Taylor
thank you very much for having me yeah
as a year said I study dynamical systems
what that means is you look at some sort
of mathematical object a space and you
apply some transformation to it and you
apply this transformation over and over
and over again and the kinds of
questions that we ask in dynamical
systems is what happens in the long term
for example if I follow the path of a
single point in my space where does this
path go does it end up concentrating
somewhere does it repeat itself so these
are the kinds of questions that we ask
as I was saying dynamical systems have
applications and all sorts of things
such as predicting the motion of planets
modeling the spread of disease it also
has applications to more abstract pure
areas of math like studying the
distribution of primes but I don't want
to talk about any of those applications
today my goal today is to show you how
even very simple systems can give rise
to very complex behavior and also to
introduce you hopefully to some of the
ways that mathematicians think about how
complicated a system is because there's
lots of different ways that we can think
about this and I want to introduce you
to a few okay so the hero of our story
today is going to be the simple circle
this is the space that we're looking at
and I'm going to sort of compare and
contrast the properties of three
different kind
of transformations of this circle so
what can we do to a circle we're a very
simple transformation we could apply to
it is to rotate it so if I start with a
point I can rotate it by some fixed
angle
so here I've rotated it by 1/3 of one
full rotation I can rotate it again and
if I rotate it again I get back to where
I started then if I keep rotating I'm
just going to repeat that same path over
and over so pretty simple so I just
followed the path of one point on this
circle what would happen if I looked at
a different point on the circle so now I
have our original path all in red and we
have another point in blue so if we
follow this point we see it looks the
path of this point looks exactly the
same as the path of the original point
right just rotated so in this because of
the symmetry of the circle every path is
going to look the same okay so now I'll
rotate by a different angle so
originally I was rotating by 1/3 of a
full rotation now we rotate by 2/5 of a
full rotation all right so I go around I
go around now this time I pass my
original point that's okay around and
then I get back to where I started so so
far we've seen some rotations that
always land back where they started and
eventually just repeat themselves over
and over again so let's try something
maybe a little bit weirder of a number
all right I'm gonna rotate by this weird
angle looks like it might wrap around
now I looks like it might meet back up
to where it started right well not quite
okay
all right now it really looks like it's
gonna meet back up no not quite okay all
right I'm not gonna bore you with this
for too much longer but I can follow
this follow this for quite a while it's
not really clear so far what its gonna
do right so what do you think will
happen if it keeps going over there do
you think it will ever meet back up with
where it started hmm well I'll just
leave that unanswered for now so the
question that we have now is we don't
know what happens with this system but
seeing as we saw that it met back up
with itself the first two times we might
conjecture that if I rotate by the same
amount
oops over and over again will I always
return to where I started at some point
will I always eventually return to where
I started maybe after making many many
loops around the circle so to
investigate this question a little bit
more mathematically I want to think
about the circle in a slightly different
way so imagine cutting the circle and
unfolding it and then lying it flat and
for simplicity I'm going to assume that
the circle has circumference of one so I
lie this flat and I'm looking at the
unit interval from 0 to 1 but I have to
remember that when I'm thinking about
this unit interval I'm thinking about it
as the circle so this point over here at
one that's really connect
did to the point over at zero those two
points are the same and if I think about
traveling along this interval when I get
to one I loop back around and go to zero
so what does a rotation look like when
we're thinking about the circle as this
unit interval where the two endpoints
are considered to be the same so let's
look at that two-fifths rotation again
okay I go over to two-fifths then I end
up at four-fifths then if I was to keep
going I would get to six fifths or one
and a fifth right but because this is
the circle it passes through one which
is actually zero and goes 1/5 more of
the way around the circle right so I
don't really land over here at 1 and 1/5
that's not a point on my space I really
get taken back to 1/5 right ok
then I keep going I add 2/5 to 1/5 I get
3/5 I finally get back to where I
started and 1 is equal to 0 so what is
happening here it seems like on the
interval rotation by a fixed angle on
the circle corresponds to addition by a
fixed number right in this case 2/5 but
we have this additional rule that if
adding the number are reserved results
in a number greater than 1 then we need
to get rid of the whole part and keep
only the fractional part remember that's
what happened when we got to 1 and 1/5
we had to move it back into the unit
interval by getting rid of the whole
part right
okay so call this operation of keeping
only the fractional part of a number
call that reducing it mod 1 and we're
for a number X X mod 1 is where we get
rid of the whole part and just keep the
fractional part so for example if I take
20 thirds mod 1 that's the same as 6 and
2/3 mod 1 the whole part is 6 I get rid
of that so 20 20 thirds mod 1 is equal
to 2/3 are there any questions about
this definition yeah so sorry keep
knocking my charger out what does mod 1
mean for our purposes it just means if
you have a number take the whole part of
the number meaning whatever part of the
number if you were to express it for
example as a decimal whatever comes
before the decimal point throw that away
and keep only what comes after the
decimal point this way you're guaranteed
to have a number that always lies
between 0 and 1 right because we're
thinking of our circle as as the unit
interval all of our numbers should lie
between 0 and 1 okay so in this language
a rotation on the circle corresponds to
adding a number R and then reducing mod
1 so this is what our rotation
corresponds to if we rotate twice it's
not immediately obvious but if I add a
number reduce mod 1 and then add a
number and then reduce mod 1 I get the
same thing as if I added the number
twice and then reduced mod 1 and I have
a little diagram to sort of show what's
going on so
I add a number that's blue I reduce mod
1 that's the arrow in red take me back
to the unit interval here so this not
dashed line as my unit interval then I
add a number again the same amount and
then I reduce again and I get to the
blue point so we'll leave that blue
point up there then if I add and then
add I go a little bit further over but
still now I want to move this point back
to its same place but on the very first
interval and that lines right back up
with that blue point so more generally
if we start from some number X and we
rotate by our end times that's the same
as adding end times our 2x and then
reducing mod 1 so basically all I'm
saying in this slide is that we can do
all of the reducing mod 1 at the end
that's not a problem ok now I'm going to
take a brief digression a number is
called rational if it can be written as
a ratio of integers so we have some
examples here 1/3 - it's not obviously
written as a ratio of integers but I can
write it as 2 over 1 I can take negative
numbers that's fine anything that can be
written in this way is called a rational
number if it's not possible to write a
number as a ratio of integers then call
it irrational it's maybe even surprising
that such numbers exist but they do I'm
not going to prove that today but if
you're interested you can talk talk to
me about it after the lecture so some
familiar example is square root of 2 pi
boilers number e if you're familiar with
it these are all irrational numbers so
an equivalent definition that we could
give is that a number is rational if and
only if its decimal expansion eventually
terminates or
repeats this is maybe the definition
that you've heard if you've heard of it
before this is a little bit of a pet
peeve but technically we don't really
need to say terminates because if it
terminates it's really just a zero
repeating so a number is irrational then
if and only if it's decimal expansion is
non repeating that doesn't mean that it
never has some you know string of
numbers that it can repeat you know down
the line but what it means is that it's
never repeating the same thing forever
and ever and ever so we have famously
the digits of pi never repeat
there are also less sort of random
looking examples of irrational numbers
so this number here
one zero one zero zero one zero zero
zero one zero zero zero is however many
zeros this is also irrational even
though it's clearly sort of very ordered
but it never repeats because I'm always
adding more zeros in between each of the
ones one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 and so on and
so forth also irrational of course there
are many many many more examples okay so
we saw about rotations by one third and
two fifths eventually closed up and
repeated themselves so maybe instead of
making the the very bold conjecture that
all paths will eventually repeat
themselves maybe we want to be a little
bit more conservative and just ask
whether all rational rotations end this
way okay
so let's say our rotation r is a
rational number which means it can be
written with M over N where m and n are
integers what happens when we have
rotated n times well we said that a
rotation and x is equal to X plus NR mod
1 since R is equal to M over N we get n
times M over m the ends cancel so we
have X plus M mod 1 but now notice that
M is an integer and X was a point on the
unit interval meaning X was a number
that we started with that was between 0
and 1 right so this is an integer plus
something that's between 0 & 1 so that
is the whole part M is the whole part
and X is the fractional part
so what mod 1 does is it just returns X
and that's where we started we started
from the point X we rotate it n to n
times and we got back to the point X so
in fact every rational rotation will
eventually repeat itself every rational
rotation will eventually come back to
where it started
so here's another definition a bit of
terminology the orbit of a point is the
collection of all points that it will
eventually reach when we apply our
transformation over and over so it's the
pass that the point the point takes so
as we saw with the 2/5 example the set
of points that it hits is 0 1/5 2/5 3/5
4/5 and we could throw one in there but
one is equal to 0
okay for a rational rotation in the form
of M over N how many distinct points
will be in the orbit of a point on the
circle does anybody want to venture a
guess yeah interesting why do you say
that and for one third we had three
points right so that's a very good guess
and it's basically correct what if I had
for example what if I rotated by two
fourths right so so maybe we need to be
a little bit careful in how we phrase it
but yeah basically the denominator when
the fraction is in lowest terms
great so you're asking if the numerator
is bigger than the denominator 42 by
seven but so here the rotations
correspond to percentages of of the
circle so we're not using radians is
that clear so that
oh well that work we're about to worry
about to talk about that right 22.7 it's
not irrational not exactly it's not
exactly but it's not by yeah it's it is
it is in fact rational because it can be
written as a ratio of integers okay yes
so sorry uh yeah
22 over 7 is is close to PI but it's not
exactly PI and it is rational but pi is
not rational yeah okay thank you okay so
we saw that if we have a rational
rotation then our orbit eventually comes
back to where it started we could sort
of ask the reverse question if I have an
orbit that I know it comes back to where
it started what can I say about the
amount R that I rotated by since we
already said that all orbits look the
same just rotated let's just consider
the orbit of the point zero okay so our
assumption is that I rotate some number
of times N and I get back to where I
started since I started at zero this
means I have 0 + n R that's my end
rotations I reduce mod 1 and I get zero
but if something mod 1 equals zero that
means it has no fractional part right
which means that it must be equal to
some integer the only numbers that have
no fractional parts are integers
this means that n times R is equal to
some integer M which means that R is
equal to M over N so R is in fact
irrational numbers so what we've shown
is that a rotation closes up and repeats
if and only if R is a rational number in
particular this means that a rotation by
an irrational number will never ever
ever close up it never repeats itself in
returns to where it started there are
infinitely many points in the orbit of
an irrational sigh in an irrational
orbit an orbit by an irrational rotation
so we can say something that's even
stronger than that right we know or
we've we've just shown that a rotation
by an irrational amount will never
repeat itself but we can actually say
that not only does it just not repeat
itself it essentially goes everywhere by
that we mean the trajectory of the point
the orbit will eventually enter any
interval no matter how small that
interval is and in math we call that
being dense okay so how can we see this
so suppose there was an interval of
length L that was not hit what we're
going to do is something that we call a
proof by contradiction and the way this
works is I'm trying to show that every
interval is hit so I'm going to assume
the opposite that there's some interval
that's not hit and I'm going to show
that that leads to something impossible
so basically it's impossible that there
is an interval that is not hit which
means every interval is hit so suppose
there's an interval of length L that's
not hit so first I want to make the
observation that if there are any two
points that get within I love each other
then every interval of length L will
contain a point in the orbit so just
pictorially if I have an orbit and two
points get within L of each other then
as I loop so I went three times around
and got within L if I loop three times
again so I'll just do it in quick
succession
boop boop boop then I'm within L again
boop boop boop
within L again and I can keep doing this
so this is kind of like what you are
saying and I can basically fill up the
whole circle with points that are within
L of each other
so what this means is that if I'm by
assumption there's an interval of length
L that's not hid that means that there
can't be any two points that are within
L of each other because if there were
any two points that were within L of
each other then every interval of length
L would be hid
so all of the points in the orbit under
my assumption have to be at least
distance L apart but we also already
showed that there are infinitely many
distinct points in the orbit of an
irrational rotation that means that we
have infinitely many points all
separated by distance L the circle would
have to have infinite lengths to contain
all those points but that's impossible
so the assumption that we made at the
beginning that there's some interval of
length L that's not hid that had to be
false that shows that every interval is
eventually hit by the orbit of our
irrational rotation yeah the point has a
size if we're not assuming that the
point the point doesn't take up any
space into a straight line so you keep
getting new else no so we're just taking
a circle cutting it without stretching
it just laying it down so it'll have
exactly the length of the original
circle great
discussion here is different you just no
no it's not each of different lengths so
the observation that we made is if we
have some some point two points in the
orbit that get within L of each other
then by just going around multiple
multiple multiple times I can fill up
the whole circle with the sate with
points that are within the same L of
each other
these lengths are all the same here the
lengths between the points that are
close too close together yeah does that
answer your question okay
feel free to talk to me after all so
okay so this shows that the orbit of a
point for an irrational rotation
basically fills up the circle that isn't
to say that it hits every point because
it doesn't but it enters any interval
even if the interval is really super
super super tiny so that's pretty cool I
think but we can ask an even finer
question than that which is okay so I
know that for an irrational rotation if
I keep going over and over and over
again my orbit is eventually filling up
the circle but does it spend equal
amounts of time in all parts of the
circle so let me just quickly
demonstrate that this isn't the same
question that we were originally asking
you could imagine for example that um I
had some transformation which I'm not
going to say you know how the
formation is defined but it's possible
to imagine that for every point that I
put on this side of the circle in an
orbit I get two points on this side of
the circle so as I'm going around I add
a point here and then to here and then I
add a point here and to here here and to
here and by adding points to both of
these sides I could fill up both vegans
but at every point in time this half of
the circle has more points in it than
this half of the circle right so even
though for this imaginary transformation
the orbit that I'm describing here is
dense it spends more time in this half
of the circle than it does in this half
of the circle is that clear that these
are sort of slightly different questions
okay awesome
okay so this leads us to one of the
notions of complexity I was talking
about earlier
so in dynamical systems we call a system
or Ghatak if the orbit of a randomly
chosen point spends proportionate amount
of times in all regions of the space
this means that the trajectory of the
point should spend half its time in any
region taking up half of the space it
should spend 1/3 of its time in any
region taking up a third of its of the
whole space and so on and so forth right
if I take any region whatever proportion
of the space that that takes up that's
how often the orbit should be visiting
that space ok so let's start with the
rational rotations is rotation by a
rational number R or ghatak does anybody
want to hazard a guess yeah
no no why right so but to be or ghatak
I'm not just thinking of sort of or yeah
I'm not just thinking of one particular
splitting or even a splitting in two
halves what I need in order to be
ergodic is that any subset whatever
proportion of the space that takes up
that's the amount that the orbit lands
in it so do you think that it is or
ghatak or is not erotic you're right
that it is not organic
the reason is basically because a
randomly chosen point let's look at a
third right a randomly chosen point just
repeats these three points over and over
and over again right so here's a subset
of the space that takes up some positive
proportion of the space how much time
does this orbit spend in this subset
none exactly so it doesn't spend
proportionate amounts of time in all
sets right that means that it's not or
got it okay so is a rotation by an
irrational number or Ghatak I see some
heads shaking that's a good intuition
yes it is or how can we see this it's
not immediately obvious yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you might be saying something along
the lines of what I'm about to show okay
so we're gonna do a similar thing to
what we did we're gonna do a proof by
contradiction
meaning I'm gonna assume I have some
interval where it doesn't spend a
proportionate amount of time and just to
make my life simpler I'm gonna assume
that this interval has length 1 over n
this is basically okay because you can
sort of get the general case from this
case but we're just going to assume that
there's an interval of length 1 over n
in which the orbit spends more than 1
over n proportion of its time okay we
could also assume that it spends less
than that amount of the proof would go
basically the same way okay so since the
first observation that we have here is
since the orbit is dense we know that
there's a point Y which is basically 1
over n away from the starting point
right in the orbit this is a point Y in
the orbit that is 1 over n away from the
starting point
our second observation which we've
already used before is that all orbits
look the same just rotated so since Y is
1 over n away from X its orbit should
look just like the orbit of X but
rotated by 1 over n that means that Y
has a sort of extra dense region in a
region that is right next to the extra
dent dense region in the orbit of X so
now we're considering two orbits the
orbit of X and the orbit of y Y is a
point
in the orbit of X somewhere sort of you
know further down the line because Y is
because of this property that all orbits
look the same we know that there has to
be a dense region for Y and next to the
dense region for X our third observation
is that since the orbit consists of
infinitely many points it doesn't affect
the overall distribution of points if we
ignore some finite number of points at
the beginning of the orbit
we have infinitely many at the end to
make up for it right y is just some
point in the orbit of X some you know
sometime in the future that means that
if we ignore the points between Y y and
X these two distributions should be the
same which means that since this region
here was extra dense for Y it also has
to be extra dense for X that means that
while we just started by assuming that X
had an extra dense region here what
we've shown is that in fact it has an
extra dense region here and here okay
but we could repeat this same logic
right for another point Y or Z say
that's you know 1 over N further down
the line and by the same exact logic
we'd get that actually X has to have an
extra dense region here here and here
this whole region has to be extra dense
containing more than its fair share of
points and using that same logic we
could fill up the whole circle with n
intervals of length 1 over n each of
which we're supposing has more than its
fair share of points but how could the
whole circle have more than its fair
share of points that's saying that the
circle would have greater than a hundred
percent of the points but that's
impossible
so our assumption that there was some
interval that had more than its fair
share of points that had to be false it
led to something that just doesn't make
any sense any questions about this okay
okay so so far we've looked at rational
rotations and irrational rotations we
saw that in the case of rational
rotations they always just close up and
repeat themselves over and over forever
and rational rotations were not or
ghatak because they don't spend equal
amounts of time in all parts of the
space the orbit of any point doesn't
spend time in most of the space it only
hits a finite set we saw that for an
irrational rotation the the story's a
little bit more complicated for an
irrational rotation the orbit of any
point is in fact infinite oh I apologize
for an irrational rotation the orbit of
any point is infinite not only is it
infinite it's also dense it fills up the
whole circle not only is it dense it's
the orbit of every point spends equal
amounts of time in all areas of this
space so an irrational rotation we see
is more complicated in some sense of the
word than an irrational rotation but in
some sense it still seems very simple
right it's just a rotation so let's look
at two points and rotate by an
irrational number so my points here are
in red and blue I rotate I rotate I
rotate and I rotate I rotate I rotate
sorry
okay so based on what we've been seeing
if I tell you where the blue point is at
time n equals 1,000 can you tell me
where the red point is yeah I mean look
we've we've watched them they just stick
together they're not getting farther or
closer apart so if you know where the
blue point is you know exactly where the
red point is right so even though this
transformation is sort of complicated in
one sense it's also pretty simple in
another sense in math this is sort of
doesn't have a really strict definition
but a system generally is called chaotic
if it's highly sensitive to initial
conditions and what this means is that
if I look at two nearby points and I
look at some time far far in the future
as I'm applying my transformation over
and over again if I know the position of
one point for a chaotic system it
doesn't tell me anything about where the
other point is going to be so basically
even if the points started really really
close together and they sort of stay
close together for some time eventually
they diverge and just become completely
uncorrelated with each other just doing
their own thing so even though
irrational rotations were complicated in
one sense being ergodic they're not
complicated in a different sense they're
not chaotic not even close
so now I want to switch gears we've been
talking about rotations for a while and
I want to talk about a different
transformation of the circle so what we
saw was when we thought of the circle as
an interval we laid it flat rotation
corresponding to adding some fixed
number over and over again and then
reducing mod 1 right throwing away the
the whole part and keeping just a
fractional part
so what if instead of adding some fixed
number over and over again we decide to
multiply by some fixed number over and
over again and then reduce mod 1 okay so
for a point on the interval representing
a point in our circle define the x 10
map to be multiplied that point by 10
and then reduce mod 1 so geometrically
what is this is doing is multiplying by
10 is taking our unit interval and
stretching it out to length 10 and then
basically wrapping it around the unit
interval 10 times so we stretch it out
and then we wrap it back around the
circle and sort of collapse it and see
where all the points go so I've
indicated some points here red blue and
green we see where they go and they get
stretched out then you take this
stretched out part and you press it down
onto the circle this is what the x ten
map is is doing okay so let's see what
it's doing in a concrete example so
let's take the point x equals point one
six one four nine okay I'm multiply by
10 I get six point one four nine I
reduce mod one so I get rid of the six
and keep just the fractional part 0.149
okay so I've Illustrated that on the
interval now if I plug that back in and
I do the same transformation to it ten
times point one four nine is one point
four nine I reduce mod 1 so I get rid of
the whole part and I'm left with just
point four nine okay once again I
multiply by ten four point nine I get
rid of the four leave the point nine and
then finally I multiply point nine by
ten I get nine nine is an integer there
is no fried
channel part left so when I reduce mod
one I just get back to zero and then
once I'm at zero I just keep getting
zero over and over and over again
forever right no matter how many times I
plug this back into the same
transformation I'm always going to get
zero out so what the times 10 map is
doing is what we've seen is it's
shifting the decimal place if we write
our number out as an infinite decimal
expansion the times 10 math just shifts
the decimal place one over and then gets
rid of everything before the decimal so
pretty simple to describe algebraically
perhaps not so simple to describe
dynamically what do the orbits of
different kinds of points look like well
we saw that for x equals 0 it's just
fixed right if I plug 0 I multiply by 10
I reduce mod 1 I just get 0
what about 1/3 0.33 333 repeating what
happens when I apply my transformation
to this over and over again yeah that's
a very good question we'll see that in
just a moment but you're right this is
this is a fixed point because if I
multiply by 10 I get 3 point 3 3 3 3 3 3
I throw away the 3 I still have 0.33 3 3
3 3 3 repeating this is the example that
we just saw we saw that for a number
like this which terminates it moves
around for a little bit and then it
eventually just ends at 0 right here's a
repeating number so this is a rational
number because it's decimal expansion
repeats over and over again 1 2 3 1 2 3
1 2 3 so here it's not fixed but it does
repeat if I move it if I move the
decimal place 1 over I get 2 3 1 2 3 1 2
3 1 2 3
if I move it one over again I get three
one two three one two three one two
three one two if I move it over again I
get one two three one two three one two
three one two three back to where I
started so this is an orbit that is sort
of similar to the rational rotations
that we saw it's just repeats the same
three numbers over and over again over
and over again for infinity so one
interesting thing to note is that in the
case of both rotations rational or
irrational all of the orbits looked the
same for one given map all of the orbits
looked the same for every point on the
circle right here we're seeing a very
different kind of behavior
well we're considering the same map
times ten we haven't changed the
transformation at all but plugging in
different points gives us very different
kinds of behavior so as you were
mentioning the orbit of a rational
number will always eventually stabilize
or repeat itself because it's decimal
representation repeats itself and since
x 10 is just moving the decimal place
over if the decimal expansion repeats
then the applying that times 10 map will
eventually get back to where we started
but this still begs the question what do
the orbits of irrational numbers look
like okay so let's do an example if I
take pi get rid of the 3 because we're
looking at a point on the circle point
one four one five nine two six so I met
this out for a little while okay sort of
doesn't look really very ordered right
it's sort of just bopping around all
over the place and I skipped ahead a
bunch but yeah eventually it looks like
it's basically filling in the whole
circle right it looks like the behavior
that we saw with the irrational
rotations where as we go on and on and
on forever it's just going to fill up
the whole circle
so this this sort of raises the question
is the orbit of every irrational number
dense in the circle for the times 10
Matt
does anybody have a guess yeah why do
you think so we definitely know that
it's not going to repeat and that sort
of makes it seem like it should cover
the circle right like it should go
everywhere but is that necessarily the
case does anybody else have a guess yeah
definitely the the number of points will
be infinite it'll have an infinite
number of points in the orbit
okay
yeah so that's exactly yeah great that's
that's the thing that we might be
worried about right that maybe even
though there are an infinite number of
points they sort of cluster in certain
parts right so that's that's that's a
great question and in fact not
necessarily not every irrational orbit
will fill in the circle so let's take
this example it's no it's not gonna look
very nice because well I did the best I
could but this is similar to that one
that we saw earlier where we have five
with zero zeros five one zero five two
zeroes five three zeroes five four
zeroes and so on and so forth so as we
noted before that's an irrational number
because it never repeats but it's also
pretty clearly not gonna go everywhere
right because if it was gonna go
everywhere you would expect only two
numbers appear in this expansion right
so we're not going to get close to any
numbers that have nines or 7s or twos in
their decimal expansion and if we look
at what this does I made the points
smaller than I did before because they
sort of get clustered very very quickly
and and that's basically all you can see
after that so it looks like it's
repeating the same points over and over
but it's actually not it's just that
these points are getting really close
together so it keeps bouncing back and
forth between these two sides of the
circle and it keeps getting closer and
closer to just a handful of points and
it'll sort of never leave this region no
I was going backwards so this is an
irrational number the orbit of which
never repeats itself it has infinitely
many points but we can see that really
it's not very dense in the circle at all
so this orbit never repeats but also
doesn't sort of go everywhere so recall
this is just the same definition that we
had earlier recall that a system is
called ergot ik if the orbit of a
randomly chosen point spends
proportionate amounts of time in all
regions of the space okay so we've seen
that for every rational number the orbit
will not be go everywhere equally right
because for a rational number it's
always either repeats itself or
terminates which is also repeating
itself we saw that for even for some
irrational numbers the orbit won't go
everywhere so for the x 10 map how could
it possibly be or ghatak if we've seen
that every rational number doesn't go
everywhere even some irrational numbers
don't go everywhere
does anybody have a guess as to whether
this map is ergodic or not the times 10
map is this ergodic yeah
so you think it was or was not a got it
okay what do you think why do you think
that right so we've definitely seen that
there are many many points that do not
spend proportionate amounts of time in
all areas of the space but there's
something that's we didn't really talk
about very much in the last time we saw
this definition because last time we saw
this definition every point does the
same thing for a rotation all of the
orbits look the same but this part of
the definition is actually very
important a system is called a Ghatak if
the orbit of a randomly chosen point
spends proportionate amount of time in
all regions of the space a random point
can be thought of as one with an
infinite decimal expansion that you get
just by rolling a 10 sided die over and
over and over again that's a random
point and I claim that in fact according
to this definition the times 10 map is
ergodic even though there are many
points which don't go everywhere in the
space equally if you just pick a point
at random that point will go everywhere
in the space equally so I want to
actually do a little demonstration can I
have a volunteer you don't have to do
anything very here
so I actually have ten sided dice so
let's construct a random number here so
what I'm gonna ask you to do is just
roll that for me over and over again
and read the digits that that come out
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow I'm actually surprised there are no
repetitions so far six okay repeat it
number now okay let's get like one more
zero okay and then imagine that we kept
doing that forever right
thank you very much all right look at
this number does this look like any of
the the numbers that we saw that had
orbits that didn't go everywhere
it looks more like pi right it doesn't
look like five zero five zero zero five
zero zero zero
it also doesn't look like a rational
number that repeats itself over and over
and over again what do you think the
odds are if we kept rolling that dice
infinitely often just forever and ever
and ever
what do you think the odds are that you
would end up just rolling the same
sequence of digits exactly the same in
order forever
very high none right it is if you kept
rolling forever and ever and ever if you
kept rolling forever you would never get
a repeating number a rational number is
just not very likely
and neither is one of these you know
irrational numbers that have sort of
hidden structure and hidden order if we
take a randomly chosen number in the way
that we just constructed then it will
spend proportionate amounts of time in
all regions of this space okay so let's
just sort of give a heuristic argument
for why that is each digit is equally
likely to be rolled right that means
that
digits should appear equally often and
often in the decimal representation we
were even sort of starting to see that
even though this is only the first few
digits of the number when a digit
appears in the decimal expansion under
the times 10 map it will eventually get
moved to become the first decimal place
right because that's what the time times
10 map does it just moves everything to
the left to the left
um ok the first decimal place determines
which of these ten regions a point falls
into right we have our whole interval
between 0 and 1 all of the numbers that
start with 0 are going to be in the
first interval all of the numbers that
start with 1 are gonna be in the second
interval all of the numbers that start
with 2 so on and so forth
- all of the numbers that are right
before 1 start with a 9 right this is
just how the the ordering on the number
system our number system is that means
that the trajectory spends equal amounts
of time in each of these regions because
each of the 10 digits comes up equally
often and each time a digit comes up
it's going to eventually become the
first digit the first digit tells you
where your point is falling so if I look
at my points as I keep shifting I'm
gonna fall into these regions with equal
probability and that just says you know
at this sort of level that I'm falling
into each of these regions with equal
probability maybe I fall into each of
these regions with equal probability but
inside one of these regions I have like
an extra dense spot you might be worried
about that right maybe each of these has
equal probability but right in the
middle of this interval there's an extra
dense spot well each roll is also
independent of all of the roles that
came before it that means that if I look
at two digit sequences
zero-zero is just as likely to come up
as 0 1 or 0 2 or 0 9 or 1 0 or any other
two-digit sequence right so all
two-digit sequences are equally likely
two digit sequences correspond to taking
that those intervals we had earlier and
subdividing each of those into 10
regions so I just zoomed in around the
number 1 here but these are two digit
sequences starting with 0 7 starting
with 0 8 starting with 0 9 starting with
1 0 starting with 1 1 starting with 1 2
right and because each of these
two-digit sequences are equally likely
and hour times 10 map will eventually
take each of these two-digit sequences
to the front of the number then as we
use our times 10 map over and over and
over again where the points land will
enter each of these regions these
smaller subdivided regions with equal
probability and of course we can sort of
repeat this logic over and over again to
divide them into each region into 10
more regions which corresponds to
three-digit sequences all of which are
equally likely which implies that the
true trajectory of our point will fall
into each of these equally likely and we
can keep subdividing and sub dividing
and subdividing to where we can say you
know the orbit of our point is going
into regions as tiny as we want with
equal probability
so really the orbit of our point goes
everywhere with equal likelihood ok so
in the case of an irrational rotation we
saw that rotation by an irrational
number was our Ghatak but it was not
chaotic right remember that chaotic
means that if I take two points starting
close together and I know where one of
the points is far in the future that
doesn't tell me anything about where the
pointies even if the two points started
really really close together so let's
take an example here are just two random
numbers I have him having them start out
close together so you can see the red
and the blue they're really close
together you might not even be able to
tell them apart but one is red and one
is blue x and y the fact that they're
close together means that they start
with the same sequence for nine okay if
we apply the times ten map they moved
over here they moved a little bit apart
but they're still pretty close together
right okay now I applied the times ten
map one more time okay they they've
moved pretty far apart now and okay
that's just sort of doing random stuff
right
okay so if I asked you if I told you at
a time one thousand at one thousand
steps in the future of applying the
times ten map this is where the blue dot
is can you tell me where the red dot is
no yes no right but just by looking at
what it was doing it's not clear at all
where the red point should be right it
could be close it could be far it wasn't
they were moving together and apart and
together and apart I don't know
so two points together more or less
means that their decimal expansions
start with the same sequence right so
these two points start really really
close together if I was to show them on
the circle like you wouldn't even be
able to tell them apart but once I've
rotated not rotated once I've applied
the times ten map four times now they
just look like two completely random
unrelated points right so nearby points
won't remain close after the times ten
map shifts them beyond their shared
initial sequence so this tells us that
the times ten map is both a gothic and
chaotic so it's sort of more complicated
than the irrational rotation in a very
important way so this is how I'll end my
my lecture with a challenge by looking
at decimal expansions try to come up
with as many different kinds of orbits
as you can think of for the times ten
map there's lots and lots and lots of
them okay thank you very much for coming
to my talk and I hope you enjoyed it
[Applause]
[Music]